i am
looking forward to resident evil which
is a film coming out in september right
now
tentatively what do you want people to
know about the new resident evil movie
um i think fans of the game will be
happy
um but at the same time i think they
should you know recognize that we want
to make
uh these characters as real and as
grounded as possible so you know i think
that
one thing i said about wesker is i
didn't want him to be
i feel like the wesker in the game
obviously has that kind of like mr smith
from the matrix type
idea and i wanted to be a bit more you
know three-dimensional than that you
know and
um have again like you know
a moral high ground and he it's not just
as cut and dry as
as uh is in the game but i think it's
also
there's an origin element to wesker you
know in this
and what he maybe was uh before he
turned into the the one we see in a lot
of the games but
i think from an aesthetic point of view
i think the games
um really influenced this well and it
kind of there's an aesthetic
that certainly when we were shooting it
that i was like man it feels
feels like a game so i think i'm really
hoping that fans of the game might take
something nice away from it that it's
the game plus more you know plus more uh
more of a depth to these characters
would you describe the movie as violent
or super violent oh it probably slips
into super violent at times
at times yeah right i'm really uh
i'm looking forward to it but i i think
that the movie um
uh deals with the first two games so i'm
just curious
when are when you're getting ready to do
this role are you sort of justifying to
your wife i listen i gotta play video
games tonight it's really it's for
work like you got to let me do it that
was the thing yeah i said tour i was
like this is because johannes the
director was like
the one thing i want you to do is uh
get into the game you know like start
playing the game i was like this is the
best research i've ever done for a game
for it for a movie this is like the best
i just get to go and play a game
so um yeah i got the old they got the
playstation out and got the game and
started playing it and
tell you what i poohed my pants
at least once it's
it's incredibly scary but i think as
well that's the thing with the game is
like more than a movie you're in control
of this you decide oh should i go around
that corner what's behind that corner
what's behind that what's behind that
and you have to kind of make the
decision yourself and
uh that's that's what's so kind of
immersive i suppose about the games and
i think we've tried to do that in the
movie you know i think we've tried to
give the audience that kind of feel that
it feels like a
horror that you're in that you're
involved in well i think for people that
maybe don't realize this is a full
reboot of resident evil this does not
connect to the other movies
and as far as i'm aware it takes place
in 1998.
can you sort of talk about um how this
doesn't connect to the other movies
yeah well like you say you know there's
no real connection
at all to uh the previous films so
we are literally going back to you know
more of the game
and with that said like you say 1998 you
know
that's when it's effectively set so
there's a lot of like nostalgia and
we're using using a lot of the gear
that was around then and i was like as i
was making them we were looking you know
the costumes i was like oh my god it's
so brilliantly 90s
that was the years that i grew up so i'm
remembering a lot of these things that
were around them
and a lot of sets had nostalgic things
from the 90s and everything so
um i think that's another factor of how
it does take you into the game because
the original game
definitely feels like that i read a
quote uh
from uh i wanna uh johannes uh
and uh he said we wanted to we even
wanted to use the fixed angles
that the first game has when the
characters are at spencer
mansion um that's right yeah yeah
so there is a lot of that sort of stuff
yeah where
i mean the spencer mansion yeah it feels
like the game at times you know it's
it's quite when we stepped into it was a
bit like going into one of those vr
things you know when you go into the vr
world
that's what it was like you know it was
like playing the game
especially like they're all geared up
with our guns and stuff it was pretty
pretty cool uh last thing on this on
this one when you think back on the
shoot i've asked you this on other
things
what's like the day or two that you'll
always remember and of course did you
borrow anything from sets because i know
you wouldn't have stolen anything
i did borrow some things um
i've got my i kept my uh my wesker
police badge and my police shirt
my raccoon silly uh my raccoon city
police department
t-shirt and badge so that's cool to keep
and then the first of my my favorite i
suppose my most memorable
i guess getting to shoot a zombie was
pretty pretty memorable and then uh
i would say the moment we were first
walked into the spencer mansion
was a real kind of like we all kind of
looked years ago holy [ __ ] it's so cool
um so i think those things those things
really stick to my mind yeah
actually one last thing what was it um
what was your reaction reading the
script for the first time
was it were you a little surprised at
what it was tackling
like what can you tell fans about it um
not that much unfortunately but i can
say that i was
i think because of the whole game
aspects i always think you know
there was there's been previous films
and i was thinking
how's this one going to be different you
know and the one thing that i've
been told by my team and everything is
like this is like going back it's like a
whole new starter and it should it's one
that's gonna try and hopefully please
the
the fans of the game so when i started
reading it it really felt like
like more like a script from a game you
know from one of the games it felt like
um immersive and it felt like
dirtier you know it felt um
it felt like raccoon city was a a grim
place to kind of be and i
i immediately felt like it was a world
that i i
kind of related to more than anything
like i've seen towns like this in
america
that's what excited me about it that it
felt relatable i think
even though you've got influence in the
game it felt like a relatable
place to live